good morning everyone I'm chef
blanckenberg and welcome to Alexan
friends we are here today as always to
talk with somebody interesting from the
world of voice and Alexa and today I
have the good pleasure of joining Manoj
and Hwanhee and he is here as the vice
president of Alexa speech AI thank you
so much for being here today
morning Jeff thank you so um I I know
that I pre warned you about this I don't
normally warn my guests about this but I
have a couple of will call them
nonsensical questions that I like to ask
all of my guests and so I thought I'd
just start with that it kind of loosens
things up a little bit it lets people
get to know you a little and so we'll
roll right into those the first one I
have for you is if you could choose any
superpower that you've ever heard of
which one would you pick now a lot of
people will say things like oh I would
want to be Superman well Superman has a
lot of powers you only get to pick one
superpower what would that one be
I think the superpower I would like to
have is to have an amazing memory so if
I lead a pace science paper I can recall
it at any time or Faraday L so that I
have all the information on my
fingertips I frequently find that no I
read it what was it about and you know
you always have those moments I would
like to have that memory which is just
super stupid memory all right I can get
behind that I could my wife would agree
I definitely need that so I'm curious
though do you have mechanisms that you
use in your life to enhance your memory
are there other tools or software or
just like
procedures that you go through to try to
remember things better no I don't know
that I agree it's totally fine I I'm of
the belief where it we're in an age now
where it's okay not to know things
because most of it you could go find you
can go look it up you can revisit the
thing when when I was a kid and I'm
imagining this is the same for you like
it was much much harder because I didn't
have a computer in my pocket that I
could just look up all the answers
I joke with my friends that it used to
be we would just have to say well I
guess we'll agree to disagree and now
now it
no no I need to prove to you you're
wrong and I'm gonna show you on my phone
yeah it's really interesting that you
know when we are having a dining table
conversation
normally you have this rules no cell
phones well guess what now I have a
lecture I can just ask exa we have a
debate going on and who acted in a
certain way or how old they are and yeah
the information is at the fingertip or
at least in sex for a wall you don't
even get at the tongue tip it's at the
tongue tip available yeah oh that's
great okay so this other one's a little
crazier but I need to know not only what
your answer is but why you picked that
one it's just two choices so you are in
a situation where you either have to
fight a horse-sized duck or one hundred
duck-sized horses I would just fight one
because I think that with one I have a
better shot if there are one giant duck
it's okay if I die I die but trying to
fight hundred people who can surround me
from all angles and just just go at it I
know I think my I'll take my chances one
was with one big one I may be out be
able to outrun I may be able to outsmart
yeah there is no amount that's true yeah
I think a lot of small fighting horses
I'm I'm in the I'm on the fight one
thing camp as well I think but that's
always a fun angle a lot of people have
a different answer so it's it's always
interesting to see how people take on
that one
all right so so you've been with Alexa
since kind of the early days you've been
around for quite a while and one of the
things that I really like to do when we
do these kinds of interviews is get a
feeling for where you came from like how
did you land here because I would
imagine most people when they got out of
college university they didn't think hey
I want to be the voice the vice
president of speech AI and Amazon that
didn't exist right so how did you get
here what was your path what would it
look like it's actually really
interesting I'll go back a little as you
can tell I've been in the industry long
enough on how my journey was and there
was no way I could have seen it
ending at Alexa but it's amazing when
you start connecting the parts ago yeah
it was actually meant to end here so I
started my career in real time systems
those were the days where you know the
responses had had to be given in
microseconds give me one second that's
what happens when you have a so I
started in real-time embedded systems
you know process control for power
plants and soon I moved into networking
because guess what networking is based
on real-time operating systems and
that's where I started working on this
new class of products where you were
trying to integrate voice and data all
on one product as opposed to having
several products for data a separate
product for telephony and I worked on
that for about three four years working
phones those were the early days were
cell phones only did voice and from
there on I actually got into this
company that was working on voice over
IP which is kind of relatively unknown
at that time they were one of the
pioneers and the reason I got into voice
over IP was because I had worked on this
voice and data integration and whatnot
and that was my first foray into the
whole world of signal processing because
in the world of voice over IP you really
have two distinct components one is a
protocol let's let you let you set up
the phone call through all the parameter
negotiation and whatnot and that's
experience I came with but the other
part is to really take this analog
signal and transmit it over an IP
network so you got into line echo
cancellation acoustic echo cancellation
compressing the voice decompressing the
voice which is fascinating for me on on
how you just take all of this and take
out a network that was meant and
designed for a very different way of
sending voice and you replace it with
the IP based Network and I was there for
about 10 years working on many different
kind of products and you know most of
the voice over IP products that are in
the industry today we had you know
pretty big minds share of at that point
and from there on I actually started
working on
while I was at that company start
working on cable modems cable companies
wanted to offer voice services and they
had to use voice over IP so I actually
got involved into integrating voice over
IP on to this cable hold of that were in
your house and now you worried about
people have existing telephone lines
existing sockets how are you going to
offer them voice over IP but it feels
like old telephony so we did that you
know and yes you know cable companies
got involved in telephony big time at
the still are as I was working on that
there's one person just calling out of
the blue and said hey I would love to
have deal with you like why are you
having beer with me but no beer will be
good why don't you just give me a few
hours of your time okay fine I'll I'll
have beer so I went there to meet with
him and they have this great idea of
taking an existing telephony that had
not changed for a long time when you
pick up you got a dial tone which is an
indication to you that the service is
life and then you start punching digits
and it sets up a call and then you go
and you start talking they fell that
time had come to really take that
telephony to the next level and they
were thinking that the cable companies
need to make to differentiate their
telephony service from the old mobile so
that people can start taking the service
and their idea was what if there is no
doubt on you pick up the phone and a
voice comes up and says hello what would
you like to do now you start thinking
well isn't it and and so what we tried
to build then was to say that this is a
cable modem in the house that was
designed to be very low cost as a device
to offer data and voice access how do I
make it voice enabled I can't just go to
the cloud because it is designed to run
voice over IP on the device itself so we
came up this great idea of creating a
cloud-based system and a very very small
think of as a voice browser but I can
render pages but they sound like voice
so when you pick up this there's a
landing page or home page and it starts
by saying Extron
what would you like to do and you go and
say comma I could actually render the
next page and and so do you want mom's
mobile or home and set up the call and
so we had we got into this architecture
there was very cloud-based small browser
on the device and and that's where I got
into the whole speech recognition and
text-to-speech and how do you give how
decade this dialogues what we call voice
user interface we similar GUI but on the
voice ID and I had no idea somebody's
going to work on Alexa likes a type of
power will be in the future.there
company did not do well even though we
had a working product and and it was
functional and we felt it was a great
product it had to a lot of things we
were you could have tweed you could get
status from your Facebook page you could
order pizza I knew that if you I said
calm I will call my mom it's my wife
said call Mohammed call her mom so we
had a lot of good stuff but anyway that
company did not do well and then this
company from New York called me up and
said hey work in a smart home we need
somebody like you who has experience in
the cloud side and the device side next
thing you know I'm working for this
company and their intent was to create
these smart devices in the house that
you can control from anywhere in the
world and have a dashboard it also tells
you how much energy is being consumed by
your PC by your power sockets by your
water heater so you have this like a
monthly view on where is your energy
going where is all the money you're
spending electricity bill is it going
and I was there for a year
created the platform launched jet and
from there on I moved into a company
that was working on Smart Grid so as you
know that there's an automation going on
electric networks and it's a world of
IOT now their intent was take a sensor
just plug it on a medium voltage wire
and it can power itself through
induction and you look for false so what
we call burden wires so you will see
those these power lines by the side of
the road sometimes you will see a sensor
on those wires is actually that's an IOT
device that I worked on and it attacked
if there's a ground fault you
gone for a large amount of current will
flow very quickly and and based on that
we came up with this whole idea that you
can even look at waveforms and predict
certain faults on and knowing that some
faults are about to happen
wow that's pretty cool so now start
thinking about cloud speech signal
processing smart home and then this
company called meetup company admired
for a long time but they won't tell me
what product it was that I would work on
yeah the only time I ever ever join a
company without knowing what I would
work on is Alexa and it is one of the
smartest decisions I made and I still
something to look back and say what made
me make that decision there's very
little information they could not even
tell me it's speech based product so
it's a cool product you love it and
there's something about the people I met
I said yeah it's worth taking a risk at
that why don't ya I would say so that's
a that's an amazing story and I think I
know for me personally but probably for
a lot of the people that are watching -
you had a career path that I think most
of us would love to have had right
you got to dabble in smart home you got
to dabble in voice you got to build all
sorts of innovative technology that's uh
that's quite a story thank you for
sharing that
so what I would tell you none of that I
I was looking for oh I need to work on
smart grid oh I need to work my smart
home it was the opportunity game like no
it's just a it's a good series of
choices that you made I think it's great
all right so now so now you're at Amazon
and you're working on this secret thing
Alexa and how early on were you in the
pro in the project we're i do i i i
joined six months before it was launched
so the lot of pieces were there and we
were getting into putting the you know
the final touches the polish and getting
the accuracy higher so it's a good time
in that sort of pressure to launch and
there are lot of challenging things you
know it's it's people always say the
first 80% are easier now I grant that
people who worked on it have to do a lot
of innovation very original thinking
but I got into the last 20% well you
trying to really get to improving the
accuracy well it's getting harder and
harder so what's all this fun times I
joined I think at a decent time I wish I
I do I came in about nine months after
the product launched and I really wish I
had been there prior but it's man it's I
mean I'm still here almost four years
later I love it so that's that's awesome
all right so so you are the
vice-president of Alexis speech AI and
that means that you and your group are
responsible for certain aspects of what
Alexa does so what are the things you
are responsible for what are the things
that maybe aren't part of your your
scope so part of my my title gives it
away but I'll give you a bit more color
so we think of ourselves as a team that
processes all speech and when we think
of processing speech we think of speed
that is coming to us and speed that is
coming going from us to the user so
that's your voice of Alexa when you hear
that pleasant voice that we consider
that part of our role because it is very
much related to speech processing so you
think what Alexa when you when you start
saying when you will many more to speak
to Alex that you will start with a vague
word will say Alexa do something so we
start with a vague word on the device we
look for a weak word that's an indicator
us so my team works on the weak word
once we detect that wake word has been
spoken
meaning that intend to speak to Alexa
then we will start processing your
speech and as for the called speech
recognition so we're looking for what
are the words you have spoken we do not
know what those words mean but what are
the words that that are being spoken
we take incoming audio and we'll convert
it into a text output and that is a
representation of what the person said
and then we give it to downstream
services for example like language
understanding that's not something
that's something that my team doesn't do
so we we are the first point where you
get into Alexa in some ways now in
addition to that there are many other
places where we had of speech so one is
what
called text-to-speech this is where you
take an incoming tax for example you ask
for music and we're saying lying artist
acts from from Amazon music so so that's
the text-to-speech we take an incoming
text and we converted into a very
natural sounding speech on the fly these
are not freaking speech it's just
generated the other part of speech is
what we call speaker ID it's identifying
who the person speaking in the house so
when you have multiple people in the
house we can personalize knowing which
person at given point was P and we call
it speaker ID we're identifying who the
speaker is amongst the household members
and then another piece of my team works
on is what we call local voice control
so we started thinking about we start
with an architecture if there was most
of the stuff runs on the cloud the
direct is there are times when cloud is
not accessible especially as you start
thinking on the go I'm walking on the
street and you know the cell phone
network can be very congested you may
have weak signal you have a strong
signal and still not have an internet
access so we started thinking there are
scenarios where what the user is trying
to do doesn't really need cloud so local
voice control isn't is is an ability to
run some of the capabilities that Alexa
has even when you don't have a broadband
and a lot of that is more speech
processing as well and then the final
piece it's what we call acoustic alerts
so this is something we launched last
year as part of Alexa guard acoustic
alerts it's saying that I can detect
certain things based on what I hear and
the user may have a strong interest in
knowing where that happens so for
example if a smoke detector in your
house started beeping you're not in the
house it could be an indication of a
problem serious problem in the house it
could be an indication of some issue
with the smoke detector itself but if
you are on the if you're not in the
house you wouldn't want to know that a
smoke detector went of any house and we
can do that because we can separate that
sound from other ambient sounds in the
house and again that's not really speech
processing per se but it's process
a lot of our dealers in the house so
those are the components that my team
works on very cool all right so so let's
get into a couple of those the first one
that I really wanted to talk about was
weak word and a lot of you know how that
stuff works so I know that that's
something that we're still actively
researching and working on is the whole
concept behind the the weight word and
its engine so what are some of the
challenges you guys are facing or
addressing as you go through that
process
yeah so as you know we are a powerful
device you can speak to device from you
know 20 feet away now think about if
you're in a crowded place or there's a
lot of noise and somebody calls your
name you may not always know that
somebody's calling your name so we have
to deal with a lot of these background
conditions that happen when you are
speaking from a distance there could be
a background speech you could have an
appliance running appliance could come
on right in the middle of you saying
certain things and you could place a
device very close to the wall there's
gonna be a lot of reflections that come
from the wall and we have to be
extremely accurate we we want to detect
every single time you want to speak to
the device and we do not want to detect
any other time so the the accuracy ball
is extremely high regardless of what's
going on in the background there may be
people speaking in the background right
you know and that's what happens in the
house right so think about I'm in a
dining table there's a conversation
going on we have a big debate going on
and I go and say like so how old is
person acts people in my you know
constant conversation didn't stop and
I'm speaking from a distance I'm on the
side of the device it has to detect that
every single time and and that's hard
and and that's what makes it so much fun
and you know when we started working on
this device a lot of people thought that
you know those things are lab
experiments they won't work in be alive
and we actually have shown it it works
it works really well and you have to do
it in all sorts of devices and in every
condition think about this we have an
echo Auto device CinemaCon happen to
every call makes a very different noise
it makes a noise and and the
there's a road noise and depending on
what type of road it is you may have a
window open even have a window slightly
open you have a vent going on because it
was hot and the a/c just kicked in you
think about all the noises that are in
the that you hear in the car you want to
just go and say Alexa call Amy it has to
work it has to work flawlessly even in
that situation yeah echo Bert
you're walking on the street you're
exercising you want to just change the
music something all of these conditions
are extremely hard and what we want and
we have a very high accuracy bar so I've
spent some time thinking about anything
I have I have devices all over my house
and you know they like somewhere in
corners of kitchens and stuff and I've
noticed it like when you have a lot of
wall bounce it seems to you know affect
the way that it responds but I've never
given any thought to what it must be
like to be on your side and have to test
all of this stuff so I don't imagine
that you have every model of car with
every type of window opens that you can
test all those things do you guys just
introduce sounds as you test these
things or do you have like a lab that
can produce that kind of interference
you're looking for how does how does
that stuff work but but we do have we do
have labs but we can test but you know
real life conditions are and have a lot
more variations do you also have created
a lot of deserts and these Texas have
you know or do you with a lot of
background noise and we can we can
create more by injecting noise of
different kind so that's the first level
second level is then you go in you also
go in the lab and you test and the third
is you know you can test with a smaller
set of users as you are making
incremental changes and if those changes
are working so much better then you can
you can deploy that to a larger customer
is very very cool so one of the other
challenges that I always think about
they must be daunting is that you know
we're in the billions of utterances a
month what what if the chat like that's
a massive scale to try to handle how do
you guys go about that what are the
challenges that come from that
and specifically for the wakeboard yeah
okay so interesting thing is that
vehicle is detected on the device itself
all the processing of the weight would
happen by billions of instructions
coming to you know millions of devices
but they're all happening on the device
scaling is not that hard if you just
think from that perspective which is I
want to be able to detect wakeboard on
and in any elected device in the house
then we do what we call second stage
cloud side verification because we have
a very very high accuracy bar and we
know that devices have constraints in
terms of MIPS and memory that you can
put on it so when a device says that hey
I think Alexa was spoken will then run a
second model in the cloud that says hey
with a bigger model bigger memory bigger
Maps is it still a wake up is it a
genuine wake up where somebody was
asking us to do certain thing now that
has to process and every single address
that passed through device detecting the
relax outspoken and and clearly that has
to handle a lot ton a ton of
instructions coming in but we have
become very good at scaling there's more
interesting problem and all of that that
you may not think about is this think
about when we put an Alexa aired during
Super Bowl how many devices are within
any year short of a team yeah I I've
thought about this too this is this is
interesting so how do you guys think
I'll be the skating problem because if
all of those devices wake up or so they
should not wake up because it is coming
on a TV and if we are unable to detect
that came over TV versus a person
there's not that much different if I put
you in a room and don't tell you where
the sound is coming from well done you
would know it came from a TV sound
quality is TVs amazingly good so how do
you handle these situations well you
know at some time you know because you
know that we place an ad it's going to
come in third quarter you know and fine
but there are comedians so we'll talk
about Alexa you know Jimmy Fallon has
this this bit where you have to make
Alexis say certain words you know
there's a lot of TVs that are playing
that show at any given point of time so
we had to invent those are some of the
things that you know as we got after
launch we started getting into the
situate
like well how do you handle this Super
Bowl is well yes and we have ice is out
yeah and that is really a challenging
problem and we had to come up with many
new technologies to be able to handle
those things that's so cool all right
one more thing and let's talk a little
bit you mentioned Alexa guard earlier
where I can detect things like smoke
detectors or breaking glass so a service
like that has to be a like being able to
identify those sounds but also being
able to ignore things like a dog barking
what what what kind of things did you
encounter and going through that process
yeah you know the machine learning model
so you have to have the right amount of
data if you do have a right of all of
data you can create models that are able
to separate them how do you get the data
and how are you able to get data with
ambient sound in my house from your
house is different between urban and
suburban is very different between
apartment buildings and townhouses and
single-family homes the noise profiles
are extremely different and then you
have cars driving by and delivery person
coming in knocking on the door and all
kind of stuff extremely challenging on
are you how do you get how do you get
the right amount of data but more
important is even some of the
applications so we actually have what we
call glass break detection so if
somebody broke your window to come into
your house we want to be able to detect
it and send me an alert saying we think
somebody broke into your house you may
want to check check that out now think
about how do you collect sound for glass
break and there are all kinds of glass
material used in many different kind of
windows and the glass values in one
country is different from others and
where Alexa is placed in terms of where
the window is it changes quite a bit
we're very creative and it's not like I
can go and you know give guns to people
or stones and say go and break the glass
let me let me record the sign yeah you
know we have to get very very creative
and I can tell you the glass break sound
on the movies is not really trained my
model on that it won't detect it only
detective Lang
Wow that's that's uh both good and bad I
guess it makes it easier for you to tell
that their house isn't being broken into
just because they're watching home alone
but that's oh that's that's super cool
all right so I'm gonna pit a little bit
we're gonna move on to the second thing
that you talked about which was kind of
voice recognition speaker ID stuff so as
we think about that like can you tell me
about how that works or how you how you
think about that process yeah
so there are two steps and speaker ID
one is what we call an old man and the
second one is being able to detect when
somebody is using the device so we need
to know how your voice sounds to be able
to detect you know who is speaking just
like you know if I meet somebody for the
first time and even if I walk away and
next time they call me I would not know
it is that it takes time for us to learn
everybody's voice is different the way
we say certain words so we go to this uh
normal process in your normal process we
will ask the user to speak four
sentences with certain words and those
words give us a very good coverage and
using those we we create what we call
voice profile
it's basically capture of certain
uniqueness about your voice if you think
on those terms so now when you're
speaking so let's say that you both you
and your wife are indoor now we have two
voice profiles and anytime a user's
interacting while we are going through
speech recognition we also start to see
is this voice matching one of the
profiles I know if it matches one of the
profile then we can say with certain
confidence that hey is Jeff speaking or
it's a person I do not know could be a
guest in the house and and so we use
that information and based on that Alexa
get personalized some of the experiences
for example if you listen to a certain
kind of music and if you just say Alexa
play me some music and if we know it's
Jeff was speaking then we can play music
that you like but a lot of that really
comes from learning how Jeff speaks and
then being able to match very very fast
as you're speaking there was Jeff was
speaking I think we're some of the
phrases are very short yeah
no it's and this is something that I
actually use quite a bit this is why I
wanted to ask you about that is because
every morning I walk in the bathroom I
get ready shower all that stuff and I
have an echo in my office or in my
bathroom I'm sorry and I could just say
play my music and it plays my playlist
for my Apple music and everything works
really really well but you said
something interesting there that I want
to dive into a little bit which is that
it can't recognize obviously people that
haven't been in my house before they
haven't been enrolled with my device but
I I think I can right I can go to my
friend's house and get it to recognize
me right you can kind of what is the
word I'm looking for you can kind of
disconnect or connect yourself to your
friends devices when you're at their
places can you tell me about that yeah
this is actually this is a very very
interesting application that we launched
I think about a year ago and super cool
so the way it really works it's we know
how you sound because if you haven't
rolled we know how Jeff sounds but we
only try to recognize between members of
the household so when you go to your
friend's house and you say Alexa connect
my device we will take based on you know
we will know who you are based on
certain information we'll ask you for
your phone number and based on the phone
number we know that Jeff is the one who
wants to get added to that device form
for temporary interval and then we will
take your profile and activate it on
that device so now when you are speaking
or other people who are enrolled in that
household are speaking will try to
distinguish between those people are who
speaking so you go to your friend's
house and say hey play my favorite
playlist after you have connected with
that device
but sampling a playlist it's pretty cool
that you can be a different house and
say hey I could I have this great
playlist they record it on Spotify or
Amazon music and let me play for you and
and then when you leave you can just
disconnect and if you don't disconnect
this will either will disconnect after I
think 24 hours or so interesting so
there's a science problem behind this I
would imagine which is differentiating
all of the voices and I'm just curious
this is more like a do we ever think
this is possible I know this isn't
probably isn't something we do today but
is there ever a
situation where I could walk into a Home
Depot or some big-box store and say
where are the hammers and it's like Oh
Jeff the hammers are down here right
like that yeah I think yeah I think that
the the way you think about that because
there's also security aspect and privacy
aspect and all of that it's really what
we you know just like into two-factor
authentication for example you could
think of those cases where you walk in
and based on some other information and
the vicinity of where you are you don't
need to smoothly connect and yeah so so
that is something you think you are not
there and somebody's thinking or Jeff
was in home debride that would be yeah I
agree so that's why you want to do with
the multi-factor okay authentication and
your voice is one of them but it could
be facial recognition or phones or
Bluetooth or a number of other factors
got it other things and then speak so
even if you you know how multiple
members were in your household when you
speak we want to recognize it makes
sense
cool all right so the next topic that I
wanted to get into is one that's close
to me because as someone that spends a
bulk of my time building stuff for Alexa
and for obviously for voice interactions
automatic speech recognition is
something that is really really valuable
to that process so I know when when the
echo came out a lot of people kind of
thought like well voice that's something
I already have right I have it on my
phone with Siri or something like that
and I think it's often viewed as like a
solved problem is that is that true I
would say this I think that that
sentiment was normally held by not by
speech scientists people who are in the
field never felt that way because we
know the challenges and we know that you
know we have an ability to solve
problems and improve things if you
really think about the whole use case is
they were very limited use cases and
that limited use case is a kind of work
and people have certain expectation you
have other speeches which are how good
can it
it's when we start showing something
that's far better I go oh you know I
example when I go into my car it
frustrates me when I because the
recognition that it's extremely poor
even on a very narrow search space which
is just somebody you know how many
people are in my contacts have 550 maybe
so if you really think or when we were
trying to launch echo we wanted to do
far field for us it was extremely
important we felt there is a compelling
and very very good customer interface it
was not a small problem at that time it
was not even you know people thought
were ads yeah in you know in research
yeah we can show but it never it can
never leave the product artists and and
now it's given you have our field speech
works and the other thing here to think
about is it has to be extremely fast
yeah you know and and if you go back to
the old speech recognition system they
were not this fast and so we have to
solve for a latency problem and then
later see when when the the vocabulary
size is big think about music how big a
music catalogs right you know they're
huge and they're always changing every
week new songs come out every day songs
come out new artists come out new songs
get very popular and then artists you
know they have their artists they have
some really good names like cache of it
all of in it yeah I would say always
actually getting is that is an example
of how you handle that situation
yeah so if you know so those are the
things that you have to solve and speech
recognition we want it to be very very
good even when we're dealing with things
that require very large catalogs
ever-changing catalog think about
question and answers you can ask Alexa
anything look at how big a space search
space and how big a vocabulary we have
to to be able to do and we still want to
do it much much faster than what had
been done in the past yeah my goodness
and now you think about a device with a
really really good speaker we're even
Alexa maybe spoken by that speaker so we
have to deal with echo cancellations
that are very very good because the
microphones are going to pick up these
are really good microphones and there
are many of them on the device they're
picking up sound from 360 degrees
including sound coming from the
the device itself so not a bunch of
challenges so this I I would say it's
still not a small thing that we're
always improving so I would imagine for
being able to do speech recognition that
there's there's got to be individual
components that kind of make that up
that like there there are stages that it
works through this is not anything I
know about but I'd love for you to
enlighten me on kind of what those are
and how like how does that work what's
the process so I'll give you what but
most of the speedy reusing systems have
what are the different components and
then you can start saying how how it all
connects so the first is what we call a
coup stick modeling I push them are
acoustic model and what it does it's it
takes all the incoming audio and it is
sending a small package from the device
and it tries to click detect what we
call phonemes or the sounds from their
audio and it'll create a phonetic
representation and that's basically
taking the audio and creating this
representation of the sounds that are
being heard next piece is lexicon and
the internet is to say okay these are
the sounds what is the word that is
being spoken so it takes into these
small sound representations or phonemes
you can be sub phoneme and and and from
there try to figure out what is the word
being spoken and then once you have this
word then the last one the third piece
is what is called language mode and the
language model is trying to really
figure out because you have you have
many many possibilities on what what was
being spoken a lot of words that sound
pretty similar to each other what it
tries to do is to say okay if is in the
previous few words what word is it
likely to be it's time to abdicate
between you know various possibilities
by really looking at what of the
previous word or what are the previous
two words what we call Engram basically
looking at n words in a sequence and
from there trying to say I think the
likelihood of this this is the word
being spoken it's much much higher than
the other word those are the three
pieces you can only see in the system
ghosting models lexicon and then
models very interesting so that seems to
be almost the reverse of what I would do
to produce speech out of Alexa right I
take words and I have to produce them
back to Alexa but oftentimes I find that
she may not pronounce a word the way I
expect her to or my last name used to be
a big issue Blankenburg was something
that was stumbled over and so I started
using phonemes as a way to produce the
speech the way that I wanted it to be
represented and in my head that's always
how it worked is that you mapped it back
the other way and it sounds like that is
actually the case so that's at school I
feel smart today all right well thank
you so one of the other things that I
tend to play with quite a bit is whisper
mode and the idea that Alexa can whisper
to me but not only that but recognize
that I whispered to the device there's
got to be some some magic happening
there to make all that happen can you
tell me about what's perma
yeah so interesting with the whisper
mode came about I think it's one of the
cool features and I did I'm very proud
of having you know role in in launching
that capability so we were we had about
text-to-speech systems and and our TTS
team came up with this cool technology
where they could take an existing voice
and create a whispered voice through a
signal processing techniques the voice
will sound you know it's the same my
voice yeah and they were play they were
trying different things and this is what
this is cool we have whisper voice and
one of the executives in Alexa was
trying to certainly arm and did you know
and they forgot what the volume level
was and this photo device at the high
school and and and speak louder and cool
if it actually could know that I don't
want you know to wake up somebody in the
house so the we start connecting the
dots and go boy wait well the user
whispers of the device and that is the
signal to us that they don't want us to
be speaking loud we know how to whisk
create a whisper voice well let us
figure out how do we detect it's a
whisper so
we were working on it engraved models
that can detect not only the words that
were spoken but even when whispered but
also that you were actually whispering
and from there of this idea that you
know if you whisper to Alexa Alexa will
whisper back and so I'm gonna push two
ideas that we've already talked about
together we have speaker ID where we can
recognize a person is speaking and now
we have this whisper mode when you
introduce whisper mode does it make
speaker ID harder I would imagine
hearing my voice as a whisper has to be
more challenging to detect that it would
be as a normal voice the way that you
registered it okay that's a that's a
very solid answer and so this does is
there anything else about whisper mode
that has offered you any interesting
challenges or anything that you were
like well we didn't we didn't expect
that I think most of them have is again
it's like wake board right you want you
want to be very good at detecting
whisper you know if you start whispering
back when you're not whispering it's
creepy and similarly if you are
whispering and it doesn't detect whisper
and speaks in a normal volume it really
defeats the whole purpose you know
you're trying to make sure that somebody
in your household didn't wake up because
you just trying to set an alarm right in
the night so for us it's really all
about how do you find the right balance
where it is super accurate it only
detects when you whisper and it doesn't
detect whisper when you don't whisper
and you know they were first time and
when you start playing with this thing
so well in the world that user doesn't
know that we have this capability and
they just happened to whisper or we miss
them and it whispered back elkrief or a
really bad experience so that's why we
had this notion when you'll say I think
you whispered I can whisper back because
we're trying to protect against that
that's my experience well what what was
that about right that's different than
what I'm used to
yeah all right all right so that the
next section is text-to-speech
right and this this is the flip side so
if we look at the process of
working through an Alexa encounter and
interaction the first thing that user
does is says the wake word and we do the
automated speech recognition and the
natural language understanding all that
goes to some code base some plates that
make some decisions about what we should
be set back to the user and then at that
point the user provides the text that
they want Alexa to say next and so I
I've noticed just in the past year year
and a half that Alexis voice has gotten
a lot more natural what are the things
that have like is something happening in
science that has allowed us to sound
more natural yeah let me take you back a
little bit I think just to show you how
those journeys and then I'll go into
what are the different components of TTS
that help us produce this very natural
sounding voice when we launch Alexa the
voice was very very good people really
has wow that's like very human-like and
now you find yourself you see where our
voice is and if you compare back like
wow we've come a long way even when the
that technology that that was really
really good there are multiple
components to TTS some of them you may
not think about as a challenge that TTS
has to resolve the very first one is
what we call text normalization so XT
could be a street SD could be a saint
yeah you could also have an SD in the
beginning of the end of the street and
the street at the end you know so you
have to normalize we from based on the
text alone we have to say is it st. or
is it Street then some some may have
number 20 and the other may have twe and
T Y so the very first thing we do is to
normalize the text well we take out
somebody in some of these ambiguities in
the tabs truly figure out what what is
the user trying to say once you do that
the next step in in that is is okay now
I know what words I have to speak but I
need to know what is the porosity where
do I put stress where do I put pause
because when we speak we have the
context based on the context so I'm
trying to make a certain point I'm
actually stress certain words or I am
just going to vary
oh then people stress in a very
different ways but you have to have to
figure out what is the height porosity
for what is being said
does it need lot more emphasis than not
where should the pause be then you have
to move the pronunciation of the words
and like you said you know sometimes we
don't get some of those words right and
especially with names you know it's not
just proper English names my name is
extremely hard for for for for average
folks and I think what TTS trying to
figure out to say this is Jase pukin
spoken like in Spanish or is it like J
so you know we have to know the
pronunciation we have to know the
porosity once you know all of that in
the old systems what used to happen was
we will have a model that would predict
the porosity and based on the porosity
it'll it'll come out with the sequence
of sounds that need to be concatenated
together and offline as part of building
the voice we would have a voice talent
come in record a big script in that
script we're trying to get every
possible sound in that language and the
number of sounds in the language is very
very high and a lot of that depends our
previous word the next word you know
many many different ways so we would
have what we called this database of
sounds what we called iPhones basically
you know previous and the next phoneme
because like an apple is different than
the Apple you know the way the Apple is
spoken so we had this database of sounds
and we'll concatenate those sounds on
the fly and but we have to find those
units that concatenate well together as
well so as part of our selection as you
are figuring out the porosity you also
figure out what is the unit in my
database I will produce that sound and
and really concatenate well not every
you know that that bit connects well so
that was the old technology it's very
concatenative and sometime you'll get
some glitches because the closest match
we had for for the next iPhone had a lot
of properties you're looking for 100%
the properties were looking for so some
of them when you told you concatenate
you will have those ramifications where
sometimes you mean get a glitch
now bad pronunciation may be just we do
not know
another world and sometime it's part of
natural-sounding if the profit is off it
will not feel natural to you at all even
pronunciation was perfect so you said
something earlier and I just I need to
know what the number is you said that
each language has a number of sounds
that can be made do you happen to know
and maybe you know so I'll top your head
how many sounds are there in like the US
English language I I couldn't tell you
that number right now I know it says a
huge number I know how with the
recording we go through a lot of
recording to to get the full collection
sounds and we always add more - do you
think it's in the thousands and the
millions yeah I did not realize that
that's uh that's a scale I was not
anticipating so that's it and within
milliseconds yeah you want all that
process super fast normalization
pronunciation prosody generation finding
the units that need to be concatenated
concatenating them on the fly and not
have any of those glitches so that's
that's that was the tedious technology
we launched with since then there have
been numerous numerous innovation on
that front as well and that's why you
see the voice finding more and more
natural because some of the
ramifications that come from concatenate
in those units where some of the units
that are following each other or not
it's very hard to concatenate them right
gotcha
all right so this leads me to some
exploration for me so I also dabble with
things like Amazon Lex and Pali and
services like that and I've noticed that
some of the voices not only offer what I
think is a traditional voice but also
what they call a neural model what okay
can you tell me about what that means
and and I mean I'm guessing maybe that's
the advancement that you're describing
that is what we do it so there are two
aspects in what you said so let me go
through the phone so systems were what
we called concatenative TTS where we
were concatenate in units the new
technology is neural TTS you know it's
neural network based and and very
similar it still has a text
normalization it has a pronounciation
then you have a neural model or what
sequence two signals model that that
takes in all of the hair and figures out
what we call spectrograph
it's basically the frequencies and the
energy level for the frequency over time
and that's what the sounds are produced
so that will produce a spectrogram that
needs to be generated and then you have
a vocoder that'll take that spectrogram
and generate a continuous stream of
audio so there's no more concatenation
going on you basically the the model
that is predicting the porosity it is
trained on first it stands on a you know
neutral data so you get a neutral voice
because that's all it has been trained
on and then you can add more training
data to it which are very specific to
speaking styles so the newsreaders have
a specific style of speaking D just
speak in a very different way the energy
level is different as you reading a long
book you will speak differently
depending the content being rendered so
we had this notion that you know just
having a really good neutral voice it's
not good enough to have a even more
compelling experience we want to be have
different styles because the content we
are rendering is different and based on
the content I want to be able to pick up
the star so then you have you pick up
and have talent record audio for those
styles so you have a neutral model and
then you augment the neutral model with
the training data for specific styles
and then you can tell the model that hey
I want to speak these words but in that
style it can then adjust the spectrogram
that it produces and and when it that
adjustment happens and you have the
voice that is being produced by the
vocoder will match that speaking style
and and you can think you can think of
how many more speakers I'll keep adding
more and more so the wheels are spinning
here just as you described it like man
there's so many different ways and there
might even be ones that are unlike there
ones that you would not normally even
want but imagine the like the teacher
from Ferris Bueller's Day Off when he's
just standing in the front of the room
and he goes Bueller like it's very
boring in Mont it's it's almost more
neutral than Alexis voice I could see
times where people would want to use
something like that so yeah I think
there's a wide variety of things that
are normal and that you expect to see
like a DJ Turin newscaster but I think
there's probably also a bunch of wee
strange ones too that you could use for
specific situations so the process is
very similar get the right training data
all right and and and based on that
greatest saw okay and some are harder
than others for sure because you know
the the intonation may be pretty much
extreme and but it's all about getting
the right data I recorded and we have
become very good at it we've created
many styles now and we feel that the the
the process the recipe we have it's very
very good good ok so one of the popular
we'll call it a style I think would be
samuel l.jackson voice i know that that
made a big splash at the end of last
year when samuel l.jackson was able to
have some interactions with users and do
a lot of the things that alexa could do
is is that more like where we were in
2014 where we had samuel l.jackson read
that long script and get all the pieces
and concatenate things together or did
we have to do we take it to a neural
level where we're actually synthesizing
and creating those words as we go in
both of these do you do need recordings
ok because system has to produce
spectrogram that matches your style of
speaking ok
and the voice characteristics so you
need recordings the process is different
in that you're not freaking creating
this units that you kind of concatenate
on the fly but you have to capture the
sense of somebody speaking how this
sound and we put stress on Samuel
Jackson that's a very unique style of
speaking that everybody knows so if we
speak and if we don't capture that
characteristic people would notice right
away but if I'm unable to capture on on
a voice talent that people do not know
you may not know that it did not capture
that hundred percent well I would know
but we have a trainee but we Samuel
Jackson you watch lot of shows and he is
a very unique style yeah so regardless
you need recordings but the the this is
a training data for model which is able
to take the relevant information out of
those recordings to be able to create a
voice that just sounds like him and and
we got Lord of positive feedback on how
real that voice
how close it is to Assam - it's really
good so I have two questions to tack on
to that the next is do we anticipate
there being additional like real
celebrity voices in the future I can't
tell you which one but I think it I
think it's a reasonable expectation okay
and then a question that I get quite
often is will there ever be a
possibility for me to use whatever
mechanisms you are using to synthesize
my voice I think there's a lot in there
but I will say this that we have
announced on poor poly for example and
poly is based on the same TTS technology
that Suzanne Alexa what we call brand
voice okay so you can just start
connecting the dots in Jackson's voice
we can create brand voices very very
cool that's just one of those thing it's
it's like the it's like the speaker ID
stuff from earlier I just I always
wonder if we ever even view that as
being possible because I'm imagining Sam
had to come in and record for a week or
two weeks or whatever to be able to do
all the things that we did with his
voice and I don't know that anyone has
the time or the commitment or the
finances to necessarily sit down for a
couple of weeks and record every
possible sound so that's a that's a good
bit of information thank you all right
so we're getting close to the end here
we only have about five minutes left so
I I want to ask one more big question of
you and that is you've worked on a lot
of aspects of Alexa is there any
specific launch or improvement that you
personally are the most proud of like
the thing that you should hold up and
say look at this cool thing I did I
didn't know there are a few of them that
go in there I would put this put in
there I think there's another thing we
did and some of them are you may say the
technology wise they're not big
advancements but for a value to customer
they're big and I index on those for
more than Oh technically what we did was
super complex I'm very proud of it
speaking rate you know we you cannot
just you can speak slow and you can
speak fast and all the people I you know
for them speaking slow maybe the right
thing and for people who may be visually
impaired they generally like to have
things spoken much faster so the
existing technology and small changes
we're able to create a feature that is
extremely useful to do to our customers
so you know some of those things give me
far more delight just just getting a
note from a customer saying hey I tried
it it's so good for me and you know that
just makes our day so I get more excited
about that then because there are a lot
more complex technology wise things we
have done for example moving to noodle
tedious was not easier it requires Lord
a loss of effort and core research and
you don't scaling and everything else
that goes with it because it's a high
compute application for me it's those
things like a few low latency that's
that's a big that's a tall order
yeah alright so there's one other
question I always like to ask everybody
that's on this this show and I would
imagine your answer will reflect mine
how many Alexa devices are currently
plugged in in your home oh let me see I
got six in my bedroom alone and say that
I have you know I have a problem I think
or but I think that this they all have
such good value proposition ah let me
see I would say I have about fifty
fifteen putting including the two that I
have in my car so a quart oh yeah and
then fire TVs with the Alexa edge I
would say about $56 in my house and then
there's some my daughters have and of
course far more on my farm or on my
account then in my house and then on top
of that is there I mean you have a
background in smart home and things like
that
is there is there one thing that like
you tell your friends or your family
about that is like the coolest smart
home thing you have running in your
house right now ah actually I have I
have integrated ring into my whole Alexa
interactions so I have adding doorbell I
have a ring alarm and when somebody
rings my doorbell my device is say
there's somebody in the house there is
somebody's at the front door because
that's what I call my my front doorbell
and then the video shows up on my echo
show I find it so cool right there as
somebody's in the house and I can see
the video right there and the other
aspect is it is also integrated with
Alexa guard so as I leave my house all I
do is I arm ring in an away mode and it
turns on guard by itself oh that's
pretty cool that's a nice integration
exactly I just walk out of my house and
I you know I like anyone speak actually
as I'm walking out and boom done right
the the one that I I tell people about
cuz I think it's pretty cool is that I
have the echo auto in my car and as I
Drive down the street I tell her to open
my garage door and the garage door pops
open and I think that's a that's pretty
cool but I the the ring I have a ring
doorbell as well and when it when
somebody rings the doorbell all the TV's
line up with the Welcome sorry it is it
really is you think about a small thing
what do me it's great I the house is
beautiful right yeah it's it's it's just
one of those it's a little bit of joy
every time it happens and it's it's just
so cool
alright what hey I can't thank you
enough for being on here today I I know
I learned a lot and I think our audience
there's been a fantastic conversation
going on so I think they really had a
lot to take away from this as well so I
really can't thank you enough for
joining us today good thank you
well thank you for being here thank you
everybody for tuning in as always we're
here Thursday mornings at 10:00 a.m.
Eastern 7:00 Pacific and Minhaj thank
you again take care everybody okay